[Music]
hi guys well we've been talking about
the upcoming AMD rx 5500 for many weeks
now in the aftermath of Nvidia's flurry
of GT x16 series launches and as they
scrambled to push out as many cards as
possible and fill all those gaps
well the 5500 xt is finally here and
today we will be checking out this
sapphire pulse 5500 xt 4 gig card
now the xt is going to be available in
two variants four gig and 8 gig in aim
the navvies lie not the 5,700 xt is
designed for 1440p and so this new 5,500
xt as you guessed it designed to tackle
1080p if you've seen the pulse under the
5700 then you'll recognize a very
similar card which boasts the dual ex
cooling because it provides extensive
calling for the vrm region and v round
of which we'll be exploring and checking
out later in the video the cornea comes
with the 2 years of warranty and in
terms of the pricing for the xt 4 gig
version start from 169 us and the 8 gig
version start from 179 us we actually
reached out to sofia prior to this to
obtain pricing for this particular model
here we weren't able to get anything
prior you know in time for filming this
video but you guys can probably expect
it for under 200 us and so that puts it
sort of in between the 1650 super and
the 1660 both of which we're actually
going to be comparing against this 5500
xt later in the video
before we get into our review today's
video is brought to you by asrock and
their new flagship zed 390 phantom
gaming x this new body is packed with
features which set it apart from others
at 390 boards it has 802 11 ax otherwise
known as Wi-Fi 6 giving you support for
that new wireless standards we have
greater bandwidth as well as providing
bi-directional MIMO support as Erick has
given gaming X a flexible integrated IO
shield so you're not going to struggle
to fit it into your case and if you pair
this up with the 9900 KS you have a
powerful combo gaming X is ready for
this new CPU which has a 5
gigahertz turbo boost comes with eight
cores and 16 threads giving you that
nudge in performance over the standard
9900 K you can find out more info at the
link in the description okay so here is
our pulse that's already mentioned if
you've seen the pulse 5700 and this will
look very familiar
forming the basis for the card we have
the dual X cooling which obviously
involves two fans or go into more detail
and get a good look at that heatsink and
the other elements later on when we did
touch this from the card so that shroud
is plastic and has quite a sharp uniform
design but one which is neutral making
it ideal to match up with other hardware
if you're not a fan of the RGB lighting
then you'll be pleased to know that we
have none of that present what you see
is what you get now in terms of the size
of pulse this card is neither large nor
small and so it should fit into a good
range of different size cases but for
those interested here are those physical
dimensions so for the length we are
looking at around 230 millimeters for
the weights you're looking at 108
millimeters and the height around 40
millimeters pulse comes with a factory
overclock which concerns just the GPU
boost not the memory and just lightly
5700 there is no absolute value for the
clock speed the power limit is what
determines the range and so the GPU
clock boosts can climb up to 1845
megahertz and the memory clock operates
at 1750 there is a dual BIOS switch on
this card which is tucked away and that
gives you the performance or quiet mode
other things to note is that with this
card we get the four gig of DDR six the
card is also PCI Express 4.0 compliant
is DirectX 12 ready supports OpenGL 4.6
and Vulcan now this card is a double
Schlosser so it'll take two spaces up on
your board and case on this back panel
we've got the following video outs a
three DisplayPort 1.4 those can give you
the 8k at 60 and we also have one HDMI
2.0 RF is 4k at 60 and of course support
for free sync to HDR Paul speech is a
single 8 pin connection for the power
and as a minimum sapphire are suggesting
a 450 watt power supply for this unit
and so not too demanding other or nut
should make it easy to upgrade to over
on the back side of the card we have the
large metal back
which supports that PCB preventing it
from flexing and also taking any knocks
there are pockets of ventilation there
to allow the internal components to
breathe
okay so we've taken the cooler off our
card for a closer look at the solution
which Safa are using and first of all we
have two 95 millimeter double ball
bearing fans and like of a sapphire
cause those fans are quick-connect ready
and so they can be removed after
detaching just a single screw helping to
simplify maintenance also give you the
option that you switch out to a
different fun design there isn't much
space to play with here so it can be a
bit fiddly and those fans also use zero
decibel technology and so when you
aren't gaming those fans will stop
spinning bro fans sit on top of this
large one-piece heatsink which uses
tripple copper heat pipes the vrm and
vram heat is distributed via the
heatsink as you can see and there is a
copper base plate in the center for the
GPU having the heatsink removed also
means that we can get a view of the
inner workings of this card and one
thing we did notice when looking at the
components more closely is the way in
which some things have been soldered on
an angle they aren't quite straight and
while this doesn't affect anything we'd
like to see more Kurt taken with the
design and construction across the board
there is a seven plus one plus one
digital phase design employed and
Sapphire includes some extras there such
as a fuse protection the driving force
behind our 5500 XT is the Navi 14 X TX
GPU
unlike other Navi cards this one here
uses a seven nanometer process and is
based on the brand new rDNA technology
not GPU and a four gig of memory means
that we have a card here destined for
1080p and something which will go
head-to-head with the GT x16 series okay
well that is our look at the pulse
complete and now it is time for us to
check out the performance by running
some games for this we'll use 1080p and
the high detail preset for comparison
we're gonna be using these otac gtx 1650
super and the inno 3d gtx 1660 twin x2
both cards are similar in spec and price
point and just to note that GPUs that
does not report the VM temperature for
the GT x16 series in size while those
figures are missing on screen if you
want more games comparison ton more
cards added to the mix and check out our
web review
for tests on that
[Music]
Oh Kane if we just come out of our last
game we can check out the temperature
readings and there we are
that is our results okay well that is
the Sapphire pulls 5500 Eckstein and a
while since we had a look at anything
that Sapphire in for a review and I must
say that I've been pretty impressed with
what I've seen today in terms of build
quality features and just overall
performance you know I really like what
Sapphire has done with the shroud on
this card it looks great and it also
feels really good as well the ability to
switch out those fans is a great idea
the maintenance and just to swap out the
fans in general we've got the dual BIOS
switch on this card too for performance
or quiet mode and even in performance
mode this card is very quiet now we've
tested this four gig version there was a
naked version which has that higher
frame rate buffer which will give you
the edge really in some titles they also
allow you to dial up on the detail
preset compared to this four gig version
as you've just seen from the benchmarks
the results place XT in between the 1650
super and the 1660 a few exceptions
though you know in some titles base MSRP
for the 1650 super is 159 whereas this
XT is 169 which isn't exactly
competitive as a standard chance against
the GTX 16 series AMD should really look
at that MSRP and lower the price will of
course guys be following up with a web
review of this card which we on the
screen in the description over there
will be kanpur next e to a bunch of our
cards and other games too but what do
you guys think of this new release here
would you opt for the GT x16 series or
would you settle for this XT here cast
your vote in the top right corner a big
thanks to you guys for watching today
please like this video as that really
does help out and if you're new to the
channel please consider subscribing with
those notifications enabled take care of
yourself I don't cut your guy
in the next one
[Music]